je suis content je suis content merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup je vais aller
vite je vais dire ça parce que l'émotion
monique la mémoire j'ai envie de
remercier tout ce qui a nourri ce
scénario il ya tant de gens tant de
sentiments je remercie du fond du coeur
toutes les disputes toutes les
tendresses de mes parents je remercie
les larmes de fanny ardant germé ainsi
les colères de doria sans qui je ne
serais pas là tout est possible n'est ce
pas je remercie je remercie la comédie
italienne je remercie le romanesque de
françois truffaut et d'henri georges
clouzot gêna rowlands tarantino je
remercie toutes celles et ceux qui vont
sauver d'une période très sombre et
m'ont donné envie de célébrer la vie de
célébrer les femmes qui m'ont sauvé la
vie de célébrer l'amour
quant à lui quand il a de l'humour les
gens qui change qui se rachètent qui
doutent qu'ils se trompent et keith
raisonnée qui se pardonne je remercie
les imprévus de m'avoir fait beaucoup
attendre avant de pouvoir faire des
films
car à mon âge on fait des films qu'on
aime voir et non ce qu'il faut faire
pour plaire
je remercie l'ambition de françois et de
nîmes et producteur chéri merci de
m'accompagner
merci beaucoup je remercie daniel
auteuil qui fut un père et un ami
j'en tremble encore je vous remercie de
tous d'avoir voté pour un film dont le
seul message politique pourrait sembler
banal mais que je crois fondamentale la
vie est courte elle est cruelle mais
elle a parfois du talent à nous de le
traquer de traquer la vie dans notre vie
vivent là avec passion ils vont avec
panache division là sans relâche
merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]